you mentioned that uh you believe we're
already in a recession we obviously saw
uh gdp contract in q1 uh we have the
white house press secretary saying that
there is no recession imminent they
don't see any signs of recession you see
janet yellen also saying that she
doesn't believe a recession is imminent
and no one needs to worry at the moment
uh what is the difference between your
view of the world and their view of the
world why do you think we're already in
a recession
i think the difference is i'm being
honest right i'm being intellectually
honest i'm not managing the expectations
of the country like those guys are i
think that's the primary job of the
federal reserve by the way is to manage
expectations of the markets
and because expectations are everything
and if you lose your perspective on
something and if you go crazy then
that's when things plummet and get out
of control so i think they want to sort
of maintain
the
concept that they actually do exert
significant control over the markets and
in a way they do but in a more powerful
way they don't the markets themselves
are so much more powerful and so much
larger than the fed itself um but so so
what are they doing i think they're
being not totally honest they're
twisting the truth they're focusing on
things like well unemployment is still
very low that's true but that's going to
change probably pretty pretty rapidly
everything else you look at whether it's
consumer sentiment whether it's housing
rolling over whether it's the stock
market crashing you can go on thing
after thing manufacturing manufacturing
is way down i mean we're talking not
just recessionary levels some things are
at all time historic lows right now that
is not good the ceos that were
interviewed this just study came out i'm
sure you talked about this too 75 of
ceos think that we're either in a
recession or we're going to be in a
recession within the next 12 months
that's for real that's no joke right and
as stan drunken miller has pointed out
in the past when you have a high dollar
valuation high oil prices and high
interest rates that always leads to an
earning recession for companies this
stuff is still coming we haven't even
hit this part yet so we haven't hit the
ugliest part of everything right now the
one thing that i'm watching by the way
really closely is the price of oil oil
has been uh kind of on a downtrend
recently and i think that it probably
has peaked and it's rolling over
similar to 2008 the stock market had
started to decline but the price of oil
had continued to ramp up higher once you
see that price of oil peak and then
descend it can descend extremely quickly
and what that does is the floor drops
out of risk on assets stocks i think
risk on assets in general are going to
crash and probably crash hard and
further than they have already
and then at that point that's when we'll
get the disinflation right the
disinflation that paul wants he's hoping
for he's gunning for demand destruction
he's succeeding he's destroying demand
he's bringing down um the the wealth
effect he's making people poor he's
shutting down businesses he's uh he's
getting what he what he uh wants and i i
think we should be careful to um uh to
be careful about what we're wishing for
because we're gonna get it and it's
gonna be ugly in the short term
obviously he has uh doubled and tripled
down on uh his promise to increase
interest rates we saw 75 basis point
hike uh with the last hike and um it
feels like uh many people in the market
are like hey man no moss like we've
already seen demand destruction we've
already seen the economic contraction uh
but they remain committed to raising
interest rates even further they're
going to continue with the quantitative
tightening uh what is your read on their
ability to actually follow through with
what they're saying given the
contracting economy given asset prices
down already so much is this just
inevitable that they will push us into a
full-on recession and people should
brace for that or will we see the
federal reserve wave the white flag give
up and kind of reverse course out of
necessity because their demand
destruction is almost too good and
people start getting really really hurt
by it
uh i think kind of all of the above i
think that they will wave the white flag
at some point and they will pivot and go
dovish again and that that's definitely
coming but first we need lots of pain
and i think they're going to succeed i
believe paul when he says that they are
not going to stop their tightening their
hawkish stance until they see
significant sustained disinflation
i think he's going to get what he asks
for and it's going to be really ugly and
again i think that the markets have a
lot further to fall they they started at
extremely high historically high
valuations from a price to sales price
to earning perspective basically any
metric you use was kind of similar to
you know
1929.com bubble 2008 those kind of
levels that's where we were um and we've
come down a lot from there but there
still is much further to fall i would
not be surprised to see you know the
nasdaq fall another 30 40 percent from
here maybe even 50 from here um that
would be um not not surprising and i
think that's the point where the fed
would pivot they would find and we would
definitely be seeing disinflation and if
not outright just deflation at that
point um that's going to be ugly i don't
i don't wish that on anybody i really
recommend that people consider hedging
or at least holding larger cash
positions at this point because i still
think there's more ugliness to work
through before the fed pivots back to
michigan real quick if i can put on my
conspiracy theory hat one thing that i
think the fed is trying to do is move as
fast as possible that's why they're
raising rates at kind of an
unprecedented rate and i think they're
they're very vocal about what they're
doing about wanting to destroy demand
about realizing that it's going to be
sacrificing the stock market as well as
the housing market things like that i
think they want all of this to happen so
that we can bottom and then they can
pivot and turn back on to uh to qe or at
least to pause before the midterm
elections i think they can't go into
midterm elections with inflation still
high and with stocks still falling they
need to try to have this happen very
quickly probably this summer crash and
burn so that they can bottom and then
turn everything back on again and get
assets kind of going back up again
before the midterm elections that's my
conspiracy theory i'm not political at
all i don't care at all but as it stands
right now the democrats are toast right
because if you go into a midterm
election with the economy down an
inflation high it's just going to be an
absolute landslide for the republicans
as far as ivy